we can bring you more now on the
sentencing of a teenager for encouraging
terrorism Daniel Harris who is 19 and
from glossop in Derbyshire has been
jailed for 11 and a half years Katarina
vatotsi is at Manchester Crown Court
morning at Katarina what more can you
tell us
yes well in a previous trial Daniel
Harris who's now 19 but as you say was
17 when he created and posted uh racist
homophobic and extremist far-right
videos onto a YouTube style channel in
an earlier trial he was found guilty of
five counts of encouraging terrorism and
a further count of possessing a 3D
printer for purposes of terrorism today
receives that custodial sentence 11 and
a half years the judge in his sentencing
remarks called Daniel Harris a
propagandist for an extremist right-wing
ideology he said you expressed violent
anti-semitic racist misogynistic and
homophobic views you glorified mass
murders and you offered advice on how to
carry out attacks the judge also in his
remarks alluded to to two separate
shooting incidences incidents in the U.S
in May last year when an 18 year old who
engaged with the videos that Daniel
Harris posted and created under the
pseudonym book a non-carried out an
attack where 10 people were shot dead in
May last year in New York state and
another shooting in November last year
where five people died after a shooting
in an lgbtq nightclub in his sentencing
remarks the judge here also said that
Daniel Harris despite his age was a
danger hence that custodial sentence of
11 and a half years which we carried out
a Serb sorry in young offenders
Institute
Katarina thank you very much indeed